this is a quick tutorial on some handy
track display settings in our graphical
viewers you may know that we embed the
viewer into many resources at NCBI so
whether you start in a gene record the
genome data viewer or in one of our
other sequence viewers these settings
can be key to your analyses today I'll
start in the gene record for human CSK
in the section called genomic regions
transcripts and products you'll see the
embedded sequence viewer if you wanted
you could pop this viewer out into its
own tab or window using this helix icon
menu you will likely see the gene tracks
in this configuration where transcript
and ceadeus pairs are merged on a single
line and there is no gene bar we'll see
what a gene bar is shortly I'll zoom
into this region where the coding
sequences and the first feature that
I'll point out today is a new addition
to the tooltip information mouse over
one of the merged rows and you get a
tooltip showing the total CDs length for
this transcript and the total protein
length below that are the mRNA and
protein positions that reflect the
position of your cursor when you
triggered the tooltip you will not see
this position or the sequence
information if you trigger the tooltip
when zoomed out too far now let's say
you want to see all of the refseq
transcripts and proteins annotated for
this gene you can go into the tracks
configure tracks menu
and change the settings there but there
is a one step solution just click on
this show all icon at the top of the
viewer now you see the gene bar in green
the purple mRNA transcripts and the red
protein annotations and note that this
is a toggle switch here is another
shortcut for changing the rendering
options mouse over the track name and
select the first icon on the left the
gear icon now you have the same
rendering options menu that we saw in
the tracks configure tracks menu and you
may like this other setting product
features
by selecting product features you see
annotated features on the protein
product such as phosphorylation sites
and conserved domains as you saw a
mouse-over gives you a tooltip with more
information such as the source of the
feature annotation
that's it for now here is a summary of
the settings I just covered the addition
of CTS and protein lengths in the
tooltips the show all shortcut the
shortcut to track rendering options via
the gear icon in the track tooltip and
product features in the rendering
options menu we would love to have your
feedback you can use the link in the
help menu or send that feedback and any
questions you may have about any NCBI
products via our support center or by
writing into info at NCBI NLM . nih gov
will be adding more tidbits in short
demos like this so stay tuned to the
NCBI NLM youtube channel including the
playlists ncbi genome data viewer and
ncbi genome browsers